en el vídeo sobre electro negatividad
aprendimos cómo determinar cuando un
enlace covalente es polar o no polar
ahora en este vídeo vamos a ver cómo
descubrir cuando las moléculas son
polares o no polares y además cómo
aplicar esa polaridad a algo que
llamaremos fuerzas inter moleculares y
las fuerzas internos leku lares son las
fuerzas que hay justamente entre las
moléculas y eso es muy distinto de lo
que son las fuerzas intra moleculares
que son las fuerzas que están dentro de
una molécula así que una fuerza que se
encuentra dentro de una molécula sería
algo así como la fuerza que hay en los
enlaces covalentes mientras que una
fuerza inter molecular sería la fuerza
que hay entre las moléculas así que
vamos a ver nuestras primeras fuerzas
inter moleculares y esta en particular
que vamos a describir ahora se le conoce
como la interacción dipolo dipolo así
que vamos a analizar por qué tiene ese
nombre y si nos fijamos en una de estas
moléculas de acetona
y si además nos fijamos en este carbono
que tiene un doble enlace con el oxígeno
de hecho sabemos que el oxígeno y
déjenme que debería ir remarcando esto
nosotros sabemos que el oxígeno es más
electrón negativo que el carbono verdad
y además tenemos 4 electrones en este
enlace doble entre el carbono y el
oxígeno y como el carbono como el
oxígeno perdón es más electro negativo
entonces el oxígeno va a empezar a jalar
todos estos electrones que están cerca
de él y así va a darle al oxígeno una
carga parcial negativa verdad y por lo
mismo como la densidad de electrones del
carbono se aleja le va a dar una carga
parcial positiva al carbono verdad
entonces ahí tenemos eso
para esta molécula verdad vamos a tener
una separación de cargas una positiva y
una carga negativa y tenemos este enlace
doble polarizado en este caso verdad
también tenemos una molécula polarizada
así que tenemos dos distintos polos un
negativo y un positivo verdad así que
decimos que esta es una molécula polar
verdad así que la acetona es una
molécula relativamente polar verdad lo
mismo pasa para esta molécula que
tenemos aquí abajo verdad tenemos una
tenemos una carga negativa parcial y una
carga positiva parcial muy bien entonces
también tiene dos polos y eso es a lo
que llamamos un dipolo verdad así que
cada molécula tiene un momento dipolar y
debido a que cada molécula es polar
tenemos una separación en cargas
positivas y negativas y en química
orgánica sabemos que las cargas opuestas
se atraen verdad así que este oxígeno
que tiene una carga negativa verdad va a
ser atraído a este carbono que tiene una
carga positiva así que va a haber una
atracción electrostática entre estas dos
moléculas y eso es lo que va a mantener
a estas dos moléculas unidas verdad
entonces necesitarías energía si
quisieras por ejemplo tratar de
separarlas verdad así que esta es una de
las razones por las cuales el punto de
ebullición de la acetona
resulta ser aproximadamente de 56 grados
celsius es decir
de ebullición es de aproximadamente 56
grados celsius y debido a que digamos la
temperatura ambiente está entre 20 y 25
aunque entonces no vemos ni siquiera
alcanzado el punto de ebullición de la
acetona verdad así que la acetona a
temperatura ambiente es líquida entonces
bajo condiciones estándar de presión y
temperatura la acetona va a ser líquida
verdad ok y eso tiene que ver con las
fuerzas internos leku lares de las
interacciones dipolo dipolo que hay
entre estas moléculas y que es lo que
las mantiene juntas verdad y la
y al mismo tiempo la fuerza interno leku
lar depende de la electro negatividad de
los átomos ahora vamos a fijarnos en una
fuerza inter molecular distinta ok ya
esta se le conoce como enlaces de
hidrógeno
así que aquí tenemos dos moléculas de
agua y nuevamente si pensamos en los
electrones verdad que están en el enlace
que une al hidrógeno y al oxígeno
entonces el oxígeno va a jalar esos
electrones más cerca de él por ser más
electrón negativo lo cual le da una
carga parcial negativa y le da una carga
parcial positiva al hidrógeno el
hidrógeno está perdiendo un poco de
densidad de electrones y de ahí que se
vuelve parcialmente positivo la misma
situación ocurre en la molécula que
tenemos aquí abajo tenemos una
parcial negativa y una carga parcial
positiva muy bien justo como vimos en el
ejemplo anterior vamos a tener cierto
tipo de atracción electrostática entre
estas dos fuerzas opuestas o estas dos
cargas opuestas verdad no no son fuerzas
estas son cargas opuestas y lo que nos
da es una atracción electrostática
debido a las cargas parciales opuestas
así que esta es una molécula polar
verdad de hecho
y q la polar y esta también es una
molécula polar así que podrías pensar
que este es un ejemplo de interacciones
dipolo dipolo y de hecho así es excepto
que en este caso no sólo no sólo es una
interacción de tipo dipolo dipolo sino
que es una versión más fuerte de estas
interacciones verdad y que así es como
le llamamos enlaces de hidrógeno muy
bien entonces si de hecho esto se debe a
que hace tiempo se creía que era posible
que el hidrógeno formara un enlace extra
y de ahí es de donde viene originalmente
el término pero por supuesto esto no es
una fuerza intra molecular estamos
hablando de fuerzas inter moleculares
pero es la más fuerte de las fuerzas
intermón oculares ok una forma de
reconocer cuando un enlace de hidrógeno
se presenta que además no es sólo una
interacción de tipo dipolo dipolo para
poder ver o para poder reconocer esto
hay que ver a que está unido el
hidrógeno así que en este caso tenemos
un átomo electrón negativo
en este caso es el oxígeno verdad
debería ponerlo
aquí tenemos nuestro oxígeno que es un
átomo electro negativo muy electro
negativo luego tenemos este enlace con
el hidrógeno verdad este enlace
podríamos pensarlo por ahorita covalente
de verdad y además tenemos esta
interacción del hidrógeno con otro átomo
el electrón negativo que en este caso
vuelve a ser el oxígeno así que tenemos
una carga parcial negativa una carga
parcial positiva y una carga parcial
negativa muy bien y es esta situación la
que necesitamos para poder decir que
tenemos un enlace de hidrógeno aunque
aquí tenemos justamente a nuestro
hidrógeno lo que justamente podemos ver
es que aquí está la fuerza inter
molecular que hay entre el hidrógeno y
el oxígeno y lo que algunos estudiantes
olvidan a menudo es que este hidrógeno
de hecho tiene necesariamente que estar
unido a otro átomo electro negativo para
poder tener una gran diferencia de
electrón negatividad y de ahí que pueda
haber una atracción un poco más fuerte y
de hecho los tres elementos electrónica
tivos que deberíamos recordar para los
enlaces de hidrógeno son tres que
esencialmente es el
por el oxígeno y el nitrógeno y que si
te das cuenta pues puedes hacer una demo
técnica verdad que es fondo entonces si
recuerda son como los átomos electro
negativos que participan en los enlaces
de hidrógeno deberías poder recordar
este tipo de fuerza inter molecular
ahora bien el punto de ebullición del
agua es por supuesto de 100 grados
celsius bajo condiciones estándar de
presión principalmente verdad estos son
100 grados celsius y que de hecho es
mucho más alto que el que vimos para la
acetona y esto se debe justamente al
hecho de que se exhiben enlaces de
hidrógeno es verdad que es una versión
más fuerte de las interacciones dipolo
dipolo y de ahí que se necesite más
energía o más calor para hacer que estas
moléculas de agua se aparten para poder
volver las un gas así que por supuesto
el agua a temperatura ambiente
líquida verdad muy bien entonces vamos a
ver otra fuerza inter molecular vamos a
ver otra fuerza inter molecular ya éstas
se les conocen como fuerzas de
dispersión de london y de hecho son las
fuerzas internos leku lares más débiles
que podríamos tener y tienen que ver con
los electrones que siempre se están
moviendo alrededor de sus orbitales
verdad e incluso si por ejemplo tenemos
aquí la molécula de metano si nos
fijamos por ejemplo en esta que tenemos
a la izquierda y nos centramos en el
carbono verdad que está rodeado por
cuatro hidrógenos es muy difícil decir
como hemos dibujado esta estructura pero
si si regresas al vídeo en donde vimos
la demostración del ángulo de enlace
tetraedro ok puedes ver que en tres
dimensiones podríamos pensar estos tres
hidrógenos como la base del tetraedro el
carbono digamos el punto central y éste
como el vértice o la punta del tetraedro
entonces en realidad es todo no importa
es equivalente en todas
direcciones y hay una muy pequeña
diferencia en la electro negatividad
entre el carbono y el hidrógeno y es una
diferencia de las pequeñas lo suficiente
como para que se cancele verdad en al
menos en tres dimensiones así que las
moléculas de metano que resultan ser no
polares como resultado de eso verdad
este es no polar y lo mismo pasa para
esta verdad
no polar así que no hay interacciones de
tipo dipolo dipolo no hay enlaces de
hidrógeno así que la única fuerza inter
molecular que mantiene a dos moléculas
de metano unidas serían las fuerzas de
dispersión de london y otra vez
podríamos pensar que los electrones que
están en estos enlaces pues se mueven en
sus orbitales verdad para esta molécula
de la izquierda
de repente quizás muchos electrones se
acomodan digamos de este lado que y
entonces eso le da digamos un estado
temporal de cargas negativas del lado
derecho
y pensemos que del lado derecho ahora
tenemos que también como los electrones
se están moviendo en sus orbitales puede
ser que de repente se haya una baja
concentración de electrones de este lado
izquierdo lo cual nos da una carga
parcial y además temporal positiva
verdad y eso y esta es la atracción que
las va a mantener unidas hay una
atracción entre estas dos moléculas de
metano muy muy baja y es muy débil esta
fuerza y así es como se le conocen a las
fuerzas de dispersión del london que son
las más débiles de las fuerzas internos
leku lares muy bien y debido a que es
débil podríamos esperar que el punto de
ebullición del metano sea extremadamente
bajo y de hecho así es verdad el punto
de ebullición para el metano es digamos
alrededor de menos 164 grados celsius
verdad así que si la temperatura
ambiente es alrededor de 20 a 25 grados
pues obviamente el metano ya estará en
un estado gaseoso
natura ambiente muy bien y también bajo
condiciones estándar de presión ahora si
incrementamos el número de carbonos
vamos también a incrementar el número de
fuerzas
digamos que atraen verdad todas las
fuerzas posibles que pueden atraer así
que si nosotros hacemos eso
incrementamos el punto de ebullición de
otros hidrocarburos dramáticamente así
que a pesar de que las fuerzas de
dispersión del london son muy débiles y
si tú tienes moléculas mucho más grandes
y sumas todas esas fuerzas extra de
hecho puede puede ser un cambio
significativo cuando estamos trabajando
con moléculas más grandes así que este
fue un breve resumen de algunas de las
fuerzas internos leku lares y que tienen
una aplicación a partir de la electro
negatividad verdad y de hecho aquí es en
donde podemos ver qué tan importante es
este concepto